chapter 1 levels of perception  trees are poems that the earth writes  upon the sky  khalil gibran all our wisdom  is stored in the trees santosh kalwara  low level perception llp sees  just a tree medium level perception  mlp begins to see interconnected detail  high level perception hlp  knows the profound interdependence  saunder the realization that each random  passerby  is living a life as vivid and complex as  your own  john koenig llp  low-level perception sees just a person  a dangerously de-sacralizing perspective  mlp begins to know more detail  like life history and goals hlp  sees a whole suite of nuance  fused into a soul  analogy has the core of cognition  douglas hofstadter analogy  comparing chunks a tree  without nutrients cannot produce fruit  a human without basic needs cannot  unleash  gifts